how's Elsa seemed weird to you we're so
excited to see you again in frozen to
Anna
we're pumped about the adventure you
take with your sister we just know that
you're going to be such an important
part of this journey follow me inside
then don't run into fire and can we just
say we are loving your new look your
style has changed and we know that means
you've changed - Papa - let's head the
trailers for frozen - have revealed the
new hair and outfits of Anna Kristoff
and Nell said we're just loving Elsa's
new clothes
keep watching to see their new looks and
what they mean for the characters Ana's
green dress at the beginning of the
movie on a Kristoff and Elsa are playing
charades with Olaf and spend we get to
see honest new green dress wearing green
isn't new for Anna her gown for the
coronation in the first movie had a
green skirt this look is a lot simpler
and less fancy it has some gorgeous
embroidery and a high neckline it's also
definitely meant for colder weather the
sleeves are pretty long we love this
casual look on Anna honest travel
clothes when anna goes after Elsa in the
first movie she's wearing her fancy gown
she stops for a more practical clothes
how about boots winter boots and dresses
but she still isn't really cut out for
facing a blizzard her travel clothes and
frozen - are much more appropriate she
switched her colour scheme to match the
fall vibes of the movie we're loving
that yellow colour her dress is shorter
so it's easier for her to move around in
and she has foods we love that she still
has a purple travel cloak it's just so
her on his hair in the first movie Anna
had two hairstyles her hair was pinned
up for the coronation it was beautiful
but then she wore it in pigtails it was
easy to see the blonde streak in her
hair in frozen - anna has two hairstyles
again she starts with her hair in her
signature pigtails but when they
traveled north her hair changes it's
half-up half-down and she has side swept
bangs we love this more mature style
what it means for Anna Anna grew a lot
as the character in the first movie she
was barely 18
at the beginning and she acted younger
because she had been so sheltered Elsa
please please I can't live like this
anymore
the pigtails and impractical clothes
showed that but in the new movie her
hair makes her look more mature her
clothes are actually appropriate for an
adventure this is showing us that anna
has grown up and matured a lot she
definitely looks more responsible which
will be good for helping Elsa
Christoph's Mielec when we first met
Christophe he was looking a little rough
after all he spent most of his life
outdoors with a reindeer when I was a
kid he was just me and Sven and
according to the trolls he wasn't really
into bathing in the new movie he looks
way more cleaned up and sophisticated
he's wearing a stylish robe at the
beginning his travel clothes fit better
and are nicer quality and he seems to
have gotten rid of his furry cat we hope
he doesn't miss it in the enchanted
forest what it means for Kristoff poor
Kristoff had a hard life he was orphaned
at a young age and only had spend then
he was adopted by trolls who are far
from human toes their troughs the
Christoph's new look shows exactly how
much things have changed for him he's
settled into his new role as the
boyfriend of a princess it looks like he
lives at the castle and he wants to
propose to Anna we're so glad that
Christoph's life has turned around
Elsa's red dress Elsa's icy dress from
the first movie was iconic her dress has
gone down in Disney history as one of
the best Wow Elsa you look different but
she has a whole new look in frozen too
at the beginning Elsa is wearing a red
dress this is different from anything
we've seen also where before even her
gown for the coronation had cooler
colors this long red gown may not be her
usual color but it is a classic Elsa
evening gown style Elsa's travel clothes
Elsa is back in blue when she travels
north to the enchanted forest we do this
to get
it's the same pale blue color we
associate with Elsa but the style is
completely different instead of an
evening gown she's wearing a shorter
dress
there's no sweetheart neckline either
she also has pants underneath which is
super practical for her adventure the
cold may not bother her but there are a
lot more dangerous things in the forest
Elsa's hair Elsa has really let it go
with her hair in the new movie in the
first film she got rid of her queenly up
dude your majesty
during her epic song she replaced it
with the iconic loose braid we all loved
through most of the trailer she still
has the braid but when she goes into a
mysterious cave her hair is totally let
down it flows free around her and we
just love the look she looks like she's
really happy in those scenes maybe
she'll wear her hair down more often
what it means for Elsa Elsa's changes
have a lot of meaning Disney is really
big into color symbolism so the red
dress is important mini fan theory
suggests that Elsa may end up with some
fiery powers or maybe it symbolizes what
she'll find in the forest Elsa knows who
she is which is why she still wears pale
blue when she travels north the past has
a way of returning it symbolizes her ice
magic her free-flowing hair is showing
her change even more her hair is let
down when she has intense powers which
new frozen to look is your favorite let
us know in the comments thanks for
watching be sure to like this video and
subscribe to the things to never miss
another video we'll catch you next time
[Music]